seuls ou avec leurs enfants certains
parents ont choisi de compléter leur
liste cette semaine bien deux mois avant
la rentrée
en général je prends début du mois de
juillet et là je finalise
et puis on laisse quand même le choix
coup certaines choses qu'ils puissent
mais sinon génial scellé par la passe en
sixième ça va être nouveau à huy trois
garçons il a beaucoup donné beaucoup de
choses à acheter beaucoup de livres
beaucoup de beaucoup d'effet des cahiers
de choses diverses et variées mais on
arrive à trouver quand même mais c'est
pas évident puisque en fait chacun veut
son propre cahier avec sa propre marque
ont des choix bien précis mais bon on
arrive à en arriver à faire en sorte que
ça se passe bien
des fournitures qui ont un coût
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire de la
caf sera versée le 16 août prochain des
allocations hausse un peu plus de 3
euros par rapport à 2010 est plus de
27000 familles sont concernées
j'ai cinq enfants donc ça nous coûte
très cher alors lycée le bac pro j'en ai
deux
section primaire les enfants de la
maternelle et une coulée par des
scolaires ça me coûte vachement cher
désolé pour le terme
pourquoi maintenant binger comme chaque
année je profite de chaque année qui est
moins se montrent moins ce docu puisque
après c'est cool donc le versement de la
rentrée scolaire ça va servir aux
vêtements et oui toujours
qu'est ce qui ne serait pas contre un
dab en augmentation c'est sûr avec la
nouvelle conjoncture
si pour les plus jeunes le versement est
automatique pour les plus de 16 ans les
familles doivent confirmer en ligne si
oui ou non leur enfant est toujours
scolarisé
cette année la rentrée est fixée au 3
septembre